[Music]
all my enemies are here
the fight starts now
[Music]
trigger warning
say hi together 12
Oh
[Music]
which huh no collusion man hater let's
go
[Music]
[Applause]
so be
[Music]
face yeah but take you over my shoulder
face
just got real
but her emails
and Tifa me
[Applause]
[Music]
Henry son what are you doing but all the
enemies protecting the forgotten man
no you're just making a mess of
everything
you and all your friends now who the
hell is going to clean this up all this
talk has consequences asshole real
consequences
[Applause]
the fight continues good you hit down
here with a real truth lies you want to
help me defeat the globalists and stay
on the inside click and subscribe
and help me defeat them because
following me on my youtube channel makes
you a leader it tracks trust me